yes I am I'm here with my sister and
we're just from our balcony now just
watching what's going on no please
there's no comida you can see like
security staff that sort of walking
along the beach and we just we heard
some more fire about a couple of minutes
ago Susan where were you when all of
this started were you outside were you
in the hotel did you see anything by the
beach by the beach in our hotel and then
we just we heard some like gun fires
like we didn't know what it was my
sister knew what it was like machine a
machine gun and everybody just started
running in and screaming and every just
the whole place just cleared and we
obviously came into the hotel but my
sister was talking to someone who said
they seemed somebody and shooting and
shot some people on the Sun bed but we
don't really know I don't really know
somebody told you that people was shot
on their sun beds people crying and
going hysterical we just come up to our
room and season we don't know if that's
true obviously there's a lot of hair
saying a lot of panic going on and tell
us what hotel you're you're at we're in
Parma Marina marina near Suzanne I take
it I mean I don't know the area so we
all have to educate me but I take you
there are quite a lot of tourist hotels
on that stretch of beach all hotels it's
just the stretch of hotels and I'm here
nothing else yeah
and you you were near the beach when you
when you heard the gunfire I mean this
is all speculation at this stage right I
know you guys are very frightened little
you can only tell us what you heard did
it sound like
did it sound like more than the one
gunman did selling more than one gun to
you it sounded it sounded like a machine
gun going off so we couldn't well I made
him head on a few times that analysis
there was like a kind of explosion a
little bit later but I don't know what
that was but they're saying it going on
in the hotel next to us and what hotel
is that I don't know I don't know what
the next one is
and we and when they say going on in the
hotel next to you do they mean that
there's some kind of attack underway it
was hurt that police were chasing some
men that's all like I know that's all
that I've been told and from the lady
that was so let me just thought write
will come up to our room
I took a video where you can see
everybody like the security men running
on the beach through the next hotel so
and there's been a staff from the hotel
looking at loose there on the roof
watching our okay